so I want to start with a question that
I might have to save for after release
um but there's an episode in the series
where you come back and you're wearing
an eye patch and it looks to me like
below the eye patch there could be some
tech going on that's covered by the
bandage am I completely off or am I am I
on to something no I think you may be on
to something
yeah okay I won't um is there anything
you want to tease or no
no I mean I would just keep in mind that
I just keep just keep in mind that he's
got a lot of money and he can commission
stuff to be
made oh I was thinking of it like an
Iron Man situation you know where
there's something going on there because
anyway well we'll talk more I guess at
another point about this I think it's
more about I think it's more about
healing than Weaponry I understand thank
you um one of the things that really
surprised me about the series is it's
more Netflix than Disney plus like I
didn't actually expect it to include the
violence that's in the series it's more
for adults um were you a little
surprised by that or like can you sort
of talk about that it is not a I guess a
typical Disney Plus show no I mean from
the writing um and and um Sydney
Freeman's direction as executive
producer and as one of the
directors no it was very it was obvious
that it was going to be a bit
hard-hitting um I always
felt um where I am right now with how
many series I've done I I've I now I
feel now that
um Kingpin is always Wilson Fisk is
always presented better in his best way
when the tone is a bit darker and I
think um I think at that I think that
they nailed it on Echo you know as an
actor my job is to you know service the
story you know however the story is
written that's my job to service it so I
just do um that but when I compare um
Ekko to the original Netflix series I
mean it it's the it's the first time so
far since the Netflix series where I
feel like
[Music]
um it's we're we're it has that same
feeling I think if people haven't had
never even if they've never seen the
Netflix series they're going to get the
same feeling that you guys did when you
watch the Netflix series when they see
my character you know he's he's he's
he's a problem like it's for sure he's a
problem and and yeah no I was goingon to
say uh I personally um I mean I really I
I am a big fan of when it's more our for
adults uh but that's because I'm an
adult but anyway one of the things I
have to ask you is um you're obviously
involved in the upcoming daredevil show
and I know that they're sort of
rejiggering the show and you know new
creatives new everything um can you sort
of talk about what you're looking
forward to exploring on that show um and
you know because King been such a great
character and um you know what I mean
yeah well I think you know we're we're
having a really good time right now like
this is this is now we've we're we're
getting back up we're going to start in
soon hopefully sooner than later and
um and Charlie and I feel like the the
right Vibe is there I think all the
powers
um all the powers out there that um
control this whole creative world of MCU
I I think they also believe that the
we're in the right place now and and
um uh Charlie and I just we speak almost
every day so it's like we're we're we're
ready to go we're feeling really
enthusiastic and uh you know I have to
say it's it's it's luck really I mean my
favorite shows Series so far have been
moonnight and Loki and we've got those
guys as
directors and and so that's pretty lucky
and we've got Dario who's an incredible
uh writer who wrote The Punisher I mean
this
is you know we're in a really good we're
in a very happy place right now I
couldn't be excited more excited uh
because of Justin and Aaron and
everybody um being on it and listen man
I could talk to you I'm out of time I'm
just going to say love your work as
Kingpin wish you nothing but the best
thanks
dude